I've been handcuffed
we're dead
[Music]
when I went to Pakistan in peshawa in
two in 2008
uh we arranged to meet these uh this
Muller who picked me up in the side of a
car so when the Muller arrived I knew
his name and my fix had already met him
when he appeared and said hey you know
when I get into his car
so I sat in the back of the car and
pretty much I'd already that was the
beginning of my kidnap we drove into the
uh what's called the tribal areas of
Pakistan it's just on the border of
Afghanistan and it was a no-go area for
us in fact it says it's got big signs
you know no foreigners Beyond this point
we arrive in this Marketplace in an area
called bajira
and I'm looking around it was like just
full of Taliban Al-Qaeda Arabs chickens
all carrying guns and then when I was
driven
up into the mountains
and I I mean I all the time I felt very
tense but I I'd always felt very tense
so I used to sort of batten down the
hatches and just try and get incredibly
calm and I would have little routines of
thinking about friends and home
so you'd lock down the emotions so when
I then get to this remote air in the
mountains
uh one of the Taliban said to me uh do
you mind if we blindfold you and as he
says that I'm looking out over a
precipice and I was like sure
he said you know it's for your own
security and then you put the blindfold
and then I remember coming to the edge
of this clear fight scene
and that's that was the beginning when I
was thinking well this this has been a
trap I already knew I was kidnapped
but you don't want to admit
the worst has happened when you don't
have to
piracy had been going on in the Gulf of
Eden ever since the late 90s what they
used to do was they would hijack the
ship and they would effectively steal
the ship's crew if you like they would
take the crew hostage and hopefully
extract a ransom to stop yourself
getting kidnapped you hire a group of
bodyguards you pay them about 20 bucks a
day each and they carry a kalashnikovic
you have seven or eight of them and they
follow you around and the idea is that
they just deter anyone really from
making any kind of attempt to kidnap you
we suddenly got a different bunch of
bodyguards all of a sudden as we were
driving through one of the outskirts of
town the bodyguard's pickup truck shot
in front of our vehicle then the
bodyguards ran towards our car pulled
the doors open and ordered both me and
my colleague out at gunpoint and at that
point I realized oh
we're getting kidnapped
can you explain why did you go to China
in August of 2019
by that time I need to enjoy a business
conference that time in Shenzhen I
understand that and much may must be a
bit tricky because that accepted time
what happens that the protest happens in
Hong Kong
and it is a bit dangerous to me then
I've been stopped and I put back to the
course of d they gave me no reason
then they say oh is because it's too
late now I need to deliver you back to
shanzan because
we we have something to ask you
something and I felt a bit worried what
happened but my
instincts and my intuition told me that
is about politics of course
so I understand is not simple
and they keep asking me to access my
phone even one message
on my WhatsApp
it could be an evidence for them to do
political charges they hand me over to a
bunch of clinicals officers
they showed no batches
and they tripped me very very very
rudely
they say shut up
don't ask the reason
you wouldn't know
we were ordered out of a car
um and just they said right start
marching up this track up a canyon I
remember one of the one of the guys
looking at me and earlier on when I
hadn't been walking fast enough he'd
sort of pointed the gun at me and went
oh you know I just have to say like if
you don't keep walking you're gonna get
a bullet in your head
um and so when we stopped at this point
I thought maybe maybe they're just going
to kill us maybe this isn't a kidnapping
uh and one of the kidnappers reached
into a bag that he had over his shoulder
and uh to my surprise he pulled out a um
a few Mars Bars and some bottles of
drinking water and he said yeah drink
drink or whatever and it was at that
point we realized that they were going
to Keep Us Alive although we had no idea
what they were going to do with us can
you tell me what your day-to-day life
was
there was very little way to spend the
time we ate goat meat uh freshly cooked
goat
and rice each day that was pretty much
it for um breakfast lunch and dinner and
then we had nothing for um uh you know
going to the you going to the bathroom
with a tool they recommended using a
stick to wipe your rear end with which
no no a stone which I didn't really
fancy so you just use your hand
unfortunately on the bit of water but
this was the same water that you haven't
used to drink with we were guarded at
all times by about eight to a dozen
guards in fact they were a very
disciplined Bunch it was like being
kidnapped by an army unit of some sort
we had no reason to believe that there
were but they were extremely disciplined
in everything they did one of the things
they say is try and form a relationship
a bit of a rapport with the kidnappers
the idea being that that will make it
more difficult for them to kill you on
about day three or four one of the guys
a young guy called Faisal he came up to
us and he pointed at me and he said you
from where you so I said I'm from
Britain uh and he went ah Britain
Britain good David Beckham Paul scholes
Manchester United uh Thierry and I
thought oh wow you know the
international language of football
um spoken even here in the mountains of
Somalia but it gave us all a bit of a
laugh it made you realize how strange
the situation was
there's a journalist in that part of the
world I knew a lot of cases of kidnaps
in the past kidnapped people had been
beheaded
I've seen the videos the al-Qaeda videos
from Iraq and that's always in the back
of your head occasion the Forefront we
knew Escape would be uh Beyond risky
because we were you had to get out of
this house
compound wall compound you're
immediately a narrow full of uh passion
villagers who've never seen a foreigner
and then you've got Taliban training
camps Arabs every night you could hear
them day in night testifying weapons and
the Ricochet this house was a passion
Family Home and at the beginning the
Taliban had told this family
it was a tribal well-respected tribal
family and the owner the the main man of
the house they told him we were spies
unbelievers so it was like again like
the movies where they would open up the
door put in a tray of food some bread
and tea or some rice and naan bread
and slowly I developed a relationship
uh predominantly with the owner of the
house this man who was about who was a
strong taciturn man
and obviously I'd read somewhere that
you know it's much harder to kill a
fellow human being so I I drew in all my
experiences of living and working in
Islamic Middle East countries of how to
present yourself and be polite
and I could sense it changed but there
was one evening where the Taliban came
in at night and and they interrogated me
I had a long they had a long list of
questions
and for some reason as I'm sitting there
the family from this house the father
that there's about eight of them all
came in these men sitting in the CR
crowned into the room watching and then
up until this point this was about four
weeks into it they believed the Taliban
that I was either of spy or an
unbeliever or something not to be
trusted and it came to this point where
of course I was answering and you know
everything and suddenly in the midst
middle of this uh polite firm
interrogation they asked the names of my
children and I just said I said I'm
sorry I I don't mean to be rude but I I
I I really I just can't give the names
of my children there's Taliban Commander
said like no you've got to mask on and
puts the gun to my head
and and I felt not I just like I'm
really I actually felt like I'm sorry
to let you down I can't give you the
names of my children
and they pulled the gun to my fixer's
head
I said well if you don't give us your
children's names we're going to shoot
him so I was like okay
it just and I and I was careful before
you never condemned them or get angry
and I I couldn't help myself this was
the only time I got emotional and I said
well my oldest son is called Luke
and my younger son
it's Gabriel and tomorrow he's gonna
next day is going to turn full and
wonder why his father Helen called and I
started crying this had a transformative
effect because the these tribal elders
and the family uh Sully is seeing this
weak Western
man realizing that he was prepared to
die rather than give up the name of his
children and he's named one of them
after an Islamic one of the holiest
names in Islam at that point the family
everything changed and the Taliban lost
face
it was a bit embarrassing for them and
from then on the family used to come in
and bring me nice food
they actually offered me tribal
protection Panna
then they put me into the Cosby put me
into the cell
and they put me on the tiger chair tiger
chairs is the chair
but they
could Buckle me up I can't move
then
I've been handcuffed and attached to the
chair
and my legs would be also Shackled and
attach the chair so I can't move
and there are three type of questions
mainly
what do you think about Hong Kong and
then they start to narrow down to get
more specific I've been blindfold I've
been hurted I've been Shackled I've been
handcuffed
and drive me onto a non-car drove me
into the unknown place
and I felt it's
very very that silent
and I heard
the sounds of moving furniture
and I understand that is some tool for
torture they hung me up
for kindness hour that I can't remember
and they try to deprive my sleep being
bitten
facing uncertain future
then they said
every time
if you wanna speak you need to say
report my master in Mandarin
I wanted to let you know who is your
master
not Britain not in English
in maintained You're Mad Men China
every time when I've been put back to
the Detention Center
lots of bruise on my legs I can't even
move
and I put into the detention center and
afterwards then I put into the personal
cell I'd be put into this electric
confinement because the state secret to
police
they don't want to
to let me to tell what situation I am to
others inmates and I felt loneliness out
of those 15 days which moment you think
was the worst most worst
of course as when the moment that I've
been torture especially the first day
because after few days that they keep
torturing me
I literally get used to it but the first
is still very very shock that they could
do that on me
four or five days into the kidnapping we
were led to the top of a mountain where
the kidnappers were able to get a
reception on their mobile phone they
told us to call my office in London one
of the kidnappers a guy we used to call
the hill
because he didn't like us and he was old
he gestured at me just as I was holding
the phone trying to get through to the
office in London and he cocked his
Kalashnikov in very aggressive fashion
and waved it at me and it was pretty
clear that what he was intending to do
or threatening to do was wait until I
was on the phone to the office and then
he was going to either fire the gun
right beside me or belt me in the face
with a gun or something or do something
so that when I was on the phone at the
office I'd be screaming like yeah do
what you've got to do to get these
people out to get these people off me to
get me out of here you know or whatever
and that was a pretty scary moment the
other kidnappers at that point actually
dragged him away from me and they
dragged him down the mountain aside and
I just ignored him I sat where I was and
they um I got through at the office and
I just said look we've been kidnapped
but we are still alive and we're not
being mistreated we're being held in a
cave and
into some mountains somewhere but that
was a big relief to everybody back home
because until that point they had no
idea or they had no certainty that we
were still alive but I remember from
that moment onwards being pretty scared
of him and the thinking like you know
these guys might start torturing us if
they wanted to and uh that was that that
made me that put the fear of God in Me a
lot
what kept you going through all of that
time my children were both a source of
strength and my source of weakness so I
hid to photographs from the Taliban and
uh of my sons I hit them in my boots and
at night I would take out
photo and
look at them
and if you looked at them for one minute
it gives you strength
if you look at it for a longer than a
minute it breaks you because I realized
I'd let them down and uh
and it's strange you know I'm talking
about it now
and it's I think when you've had a very
intense traumatic experience you never
it never Fades from memories to the
minute you know I've just
you know but you can immediately be back
there I would kneel by my bed
uh as I Would by the bath in London when
I would it was bath time for my two boys
so they were their babies so
at the time I knew they were being baths
in London I I would kneel down close my
eyes and because I was just stuck in
this dark self a few four months within
seconds I was there and I could feel the
Contours of the skin beneath I could
hear them squealing with delight
so I would bathe them every day so
things like that to keep you going one
morning
um a couple of guys who uh were clearly
not from the The Gang That was holding
us uh turned up at the cave outside we
couldn't see what was going on but we
could hear gunfire these two guys who
had been kicked out suddenly reappeared
on a distant Cliff Edge that overlooked
our cave
um with a couple of their colleagues and
they started firing down into our cave
with their own guns it was like being in
a some wild west movie it was bullets
pinging around all this sort of thing
um to make matters worse
um uh one of the kidnappers who was with
us then decided that we would be safer
if we were actually hidden behind some
rocks outside of the cave there was a
big pile of Boulders there so uh he got
a big machine gun with a bullet belt
that he wrapped around his shoulders
looking like Rambo and said right come
on out this way so we followed him out
and he hid us behind these Boulders and
um uh said like lie down in that space
there unfortunately this this set of
Boulders was also the place that we've
been using for the last couple of weeks
as our main toilet area you know I've
got a choice here either
um lie down and in a pool of my own sort
of piss or keep my head up I'm just
getting it shut off
um I think it's fair to say that was a
kind of that was a low point in the
whole thing
the worst thing can happen to a hostage
is you'll get your hopes raised so there
was at one point the Taliban Commander
came in burst into the room with a SAT
phone saying great news your TV company
want to negotiate I'm like
I know and I could think I'm going to
see my kids at last
and he said but that's gone out got
something's gone wrong with negotiations
so I need to phone your TV company and
say we're going to kill your fixer if
they don't pay this money and then he
looked to me conspiratory like we're all
in this together he said look don't
worry we ain't really going to kill him
uh we just say that when we negotiating
kind of this is just a game
I make this telephone call and I get
this hello switchboard
and somehow think that beautiful Estuary
voice that London voice
it was like oh God I could almost feel I
was back home and I said look I'm really
sorry a bit of an odd one this my name's
Sean Lang and I've been kidnapped I'm
calling from the tribalist can you put
me through to current affairs ahead of
news and
and then I hear this delay and then she
goes how do you spell Sean Langan and
I'm like I'm really sorry long as you
kidnapped and I'm like I'm really sorry
I don't mean to freak out but I'm pretty
sure he's going to shoot my fix if you
don't pull me through whatever you do
don't put me on hold
or voicemail just put me through to
someone she goes putting you straight
through and I get put through to
voicemail
and I'm down to like ten dollars and I
take it off and trying to explain to
Taliban Commander
that you've been put through to
voicemail he was like what the
voicemail and he said and he just said
don't these foreigners get it we kill
people just to prove it and it just at
this point played right at me said call
the back and I just
see this you just go
and I and I I just think oh God and I I
look down there and there's my fix here
and I think he shot him and he's just
sprayed over the head and he just
he just looks me he says someone wants
you dead something's wrong and he leaves
the compound
and then we're back in ourselves so that
was and then and then that was the
hardest time because then it's like all
hope was lost
the family now came in one that said
would you like to convert and I was
convinced
because they said it's not good to die
without converting
so these were my last rights I've been
given a hot shower some food
and then in fact when the Taliban came
back it looked like there was a guy
there whose job it was he had a big
knife and I said look
uh
uh I couldn't can I make one request uh
do you mind though if you you should I
could be shot in the head and they then
discussed this and the Muller
another Mueller was discussing and they
said yeah yeah okay
you will grant you that so then it's
like oh my God so I am being executed
and without thinking about and they said
the owner of the house you know I'd
really go wrong and I said do you mind
very much can I ask him to be the guy
who shoots me
because my feeling was if you're going
to be shot it's that horrible moment of
fear like I'm mugging but actually if
it's someone you like and if you've
spent time with who's putting out of
your misery it's it's just like
he was so touched that I appointed him
my executioner he cried and the Taliban
Commander sits down and it's like a
court hearing and I have to sit there
and he's acting as the judge and he he
opens up these official papers and he
reads it out he says the the Taliban
Surah
has found you innocent of all charges
and accepts you are a journalist and I'm
like and so it was literally when you're
innocent of all charges and I went
good one
and then he said with great comedic time
you pause he let me enjoy my mom and
said
but they voted to kill you to send a
message to other journalists not to try
this again I'm like
and I literally went oh I thought oh
and I'm sitting there
and then he pauses
he says but don't worry the Emirates
threat tokany and I we vetoed the shower
so you're free to go so within a space
of a minute I'd been told you're
innocent we're gonna kill you
don't worry you can go and I'm just in
tatters and then they read out my fixes
Charlie said you have been the court
sure find you guilty of all the charges
but we're going to allow you to go
in fact we knew that meant he wasn't
going to be allowed to go
and uh and the year before an Italian
journalist and an Afghan fixer had been
kidnapped and they let the Italian go
and they killed the the Afghan fixer and
they were friends of ours the Afghan
and I made a promise to my fixer that I
that
we would either both live or we would
both die
can you explain how you were eventually
freed after six weeks in captivity we
were told by the kidnappers that we were
finally going to be freed we weren't
told why we were getting freed uh we got
a phone call from London saying tomorrow
morning you will be taken to a
rendezvous Point elsewhere in the
mountains and it will be met by a group
of Somali Clan leaders who have agreed
to act as Gilberto tweens in the
situation and you will be handed over to
them there was about 50 guys
there all armed to the teeth with rocket
propelled grenades belt fed machine guns
anti-aircraft guns mounted on the back
of pickup trucks it's a small army we
were driven up over a mountain pass
where we stopped and told to get out the
car so we Julie walked down this path
hands up like this expecting to hear
bullets suddenly erupting at any minute
or and that the whole thing will end in
disaster uh we Julie got down at the
bottom and we were handed over and uh
one of these Somali Elders
sort of elderly man in a suit he said ah
you know um welcome you are now free
I remember there was a moment when we
were handed over to the uh the clan
Elder I turned around and I looked at
the the lead kidnapper and I thought
what are you supposed to say or do in
this situation you know you're supposed
to sort of um uh tell me
um or something like that uh uh and you
know hope that you'll see him in court
one day or do you sort of say well
actually you know you didn't mistreat us
too much
um he was actually quite professional
about the whole thing maybe shake his
hand no I don't think so and just as I
was making up my mind and wondering
whether to just kind of Nod farewell he
turned away and marched up the hill
anyway without so much his Second Glance
so why do you think the Chinese
authorities let you go that time my
family members and my girlfriend uh
report my missing in Hong Kong
so that time
it becomes a global news headline
and I think that is one of the reason it
actually could help me because when I
look back when the week that they
started to stop the torture is exactly
when the newts and the media report to
my missing case globally they felt
pressure
I try my best to be cooperative why I
need to rescue my life
um
I don't want to betray to my my friends
my protesters that I know
and I try Pastor deny
deny the charges they claim that
I work for the UK government
to stigmatize the UK government to prove
the UK government is behind the scenes
for the protest that is what the Beijing
want to do their own propaganda they
said that as a foreign power and
manipulation
they could trigger the nationalism
blightful blight nationalism whether
people stick with the regime's dick with
the government
that's what they wanted me to play that
role that almost immediately when I
finished the reports to the British
Consulate what happened to them
what happened to me as well
then I left
and I didn't even tell to my family
members to say I never have a good
comeback no it just pretends
as usual
I just try to spend the last few days
with my family members I understand that
maybe the last few days for the rest of
my life to be with them but I can't
speak it out because
they're too old to take that
they're too old to understand the
complexity of the matter and suddenly I
took the flight to Taiwan
I felt that's about the time I need to
talk with the BBC
that is about the time that
I blatantly I publicly broke the promise
with the State security police in
mainland China to say look I speak out
so for now I'm an activist I say I'm a
non-profit organization I try to
solidify to Hong kongness in the UK on
August 2020
I have been reportedly on the want list
by the Hong Kong National Security
Police
the claim the State security law from
Hong Kong could operate globally
regardless
workout nationalities you're holding
so
that is almost always the risk to me
we were brought out into this Courtyard
now I hadn't seen sunlight for three
months
and I see my skin for the first time and
I'd lost three stone in weight and I'm
thinking
and that's when they're negotiating with
my negotiators and they say we've got it
and they're talking about this package
we've got the package we're going to
deliver and I said to the guy on the
phone I said no no you tell him I'm not
going you have to kill me
and he's looking at me and all the
guards and I mean I'm like well
and unless you release my fix I'm not
doing it and I turned away and I'm say
to God I've got about 10 seconds of this
kind of faux courage that if if by if if
this doesn't work every senior in my
body wants to be released to meet my
children
they look thinking Steel's about to fall
through and they went all right we'll
release the fixture as well and and we
were released together and some
we've bonded out of the back of a car
I've got a hood taken off and this Big
Fat American guy
shakes my hands as a welcome home sir
and I start crying
I went I'll blow your head off I
went out about that yes Jacob you punch
man knocked him out one punch this man
dead he can't be dead I've just killed
someone
[Music]
laughs